- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook
and Twitter to keep up with the
latest programs.
- We are the paradoxical ape, bipedal,
naked, large brained, long the master of
fire, tools, and language. But still
trying to understand ourselves. Aware that
death is inevitable yet filled with
optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand down
knowledge. We empathize and deceive. We
shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here.
An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
- [Jeff Severinghaus] So I study ice cores
and I'm just an arm chair admirer of the
people who study evolution of humans. So
I'm very pleased to be invited here and I
hope I can contribute something. My
outline is that first I'll take a little
digression away from the topic of human
evolution just to give you some background
on what's happening right now and how, for
example, do we know that humans are
causing the current climate change. And
then I'll talk about the the observations
made by many other people, not myself,
that agriculture seems to have originated
precisely when we had the most recent of
these abrupt climate change events 11.7
thousand years ago. Some people call that
the end of the Younger Dryas Period. And
it's really quite a stunning coincidence
and it probably isn't a coincidence. Many
people now believe that the warming and
the wetting allowed humans to switch from
a hunting and gathering mode of existence
to an agricultural mode of existence.
And then I'll go on to talk about abrupt
climate change itself and what causes it.
I'll tell you the punchline which is that
we think it's the switching on and off of
ocean circulation. And I'll wrap up with a
question, will it happen again in the
future? So my little digression, the
"smoking gun" of human causation, I love
this diagram and you don't see it in the
media very often.
I think it's a shame that we don't
because it really is a very powerful form
of evidence and if someone asks you if you
believe in global warming you should say
"No" because it's not a matter of belief,
it's a matter of evidence. So this is from
the Ice Cores, I'm proud to say. This is
my field of Ice Cores science. We know the
bubbles trapped in ice cores that CO2 in
the atmosphere was about 280 parts per
million for most of the last thousand
years and then right around the time of
major coal burning, around 1850, it
started to creep up. Here we are today at
400 parts per million. And at the same
time this rare isotope of carbon that
Peter deMenocal introduced, Carbon-13, in
the atmospheric CO2 changed from a very
stable value, don't worry about these
units, and it started taking a nose-dive
and that's the signature of fossil fuel
burning. If the CO2 was coming from the
ocean, which is the major natural source
of CO2, it would not have done this. It
would've been flat. This really is the
smoking gun. You can say that with great,
great confidence. And of course, there's a
lot of other lines of evidence but I like
this in particular. The other thing that
you can do if you're confronted by someone
who doesn't buy this argument, how do we
know that CO2 actually causes climate
change, you can look to our neighbor,
Venus, which has about three thousand
times more CO2 in its atmosphere than our
planet and it has a surface temperature of
450 centigrade which is hot enough to melt
lead. So it's basically a combination of
Venus, basic physics that tells us that
CO2 traps heat, and these undisputed
measurements of CO2 concentration
and it's isotopes.
Those three three things taken together
pretty much sums it all up.
Everything else is kind of details.
We know that humans are
embarking on a dramatic future change of
climate. It doesn't really matter that
much what's happened up until now. I mean
asking whether the earth is warming or not
is kind of like driving towards a cliff
and asking "Are we dropping yet?" It's not
really that interesting a question,
actually? And while I'm on the topic of
smoking guns, this is a very famous
picture that many people have seen. The
CO2 concentration from ice cores and here
we are here today at 400. So you see it is
quite unusual in the context of the last
800 thousand years which is the whole ice
core record. I'm working on trying to
extend this back to 1.5 million years. You
can ask me about that later if you want.
But the important about this is that this
is not the smoking gun of human causation.
There has been awful lot of confusion
about this. Al Gore, bless his heart, I
think kind of lead us down the wrong path
by implying that this was some kind of
evidence that CO2 causes climate change.
In fact, it's mostly the other way around.
That Antarctic temperatures related to
the things that control natural variations
in CO2 and the current CO2 spike has
nothing to do with these variations. It's
not coming from the ocean as you saw from
the Carbon-13 evidence. It's coming from
fossil fuel. It's a completely different
chemical, in fact. So if somebody
gives you a hard time about the fact that
the CO2 changes slightly after the
temperature, you can tell them that's
expected because it's natural CO2 and it's
responding to climate.
It's not causing climate.
A related myth is that the ice core
record that you've just seen shows that
carbon dioxide rose after temperature
began warming at the ends of ice ages,
which is true. That's why it's in black.
Ergo carbon dioxide does not cause
warming, which is false. The fact is that
ice ages are ended by the changes in the
earth's orbit as you heard earlier today.
So it's not surprising that the
temperature change is first. And you can
think of CO2 as a feedback that amplifies
the initial warming by about 30% probably.
It's actually not a huge increase. It's
maybe two degrees bigger of change than
you would've gotten otherwise. So humans
are adding CO2 directly to the atmosphere
and so ice ages are not a good analog.
It's a red herring. I couldn't resist
showing this because it's such an nice
analogy. If you overspend your credit
card, you go into debt, then you have to
pay interest, right? And that makes more
debt. So interest lags debt. How do we
know that interest adds to debt? We can't
explain the total size of the debt without
taking into account interest and also
economics tells us. And climate of the
past now, we have the earth's orbit
causing warming, making CO2 rise as the
oceans warms and out gasses and CO2 and
that causes further warming as an
amplifier. That's the hole end of story
about human caused climate change.
Now I"m going to move on to this idea that
the first evidence for agriculture was
seen during this abrupt warming. So this
is a fascinating topic and it's mostly, I
think, the work of Brian Baird, who used
to be here at UCSD, who discovered that
the very, very first domesticated plants,
I think they were barley seeds, would
occur within plus or minus 200 years of
this abrupt warming event right here.
Seeing that this is actually
the Greenland
temperature but it's a lot of the
Northern Hemisphere,
European temperature as well.
And then this is a methane, atmospheric
methane record from the ice core and it
seems to be a proxy for wetness.
There's a great deal of increase in
northern hemisphere, low latitude rain
fall at this time. And this all happened
in about 30 years. These are very fast
events. There's about half of the
temperature change seems to have occurred
in one year. These are the kind of things
that could impose very large stresses on
humans potentially because there's not
enough time to adapt. And so what's
amazing about this that people seem to
have completely changed in a very short
time their mode of existence from a
hunting and gathering to farming right
here. And it's probably because everything
got so much warmer and wetter. It just
really lush. Think of the Garden of Eden.
That's probably some time in here. We
don't know whether it was 8 thousand years
or 12 thousand years, whatever. That was
an example of an abrupt climate change
that greatly benefited our ancestors. Of
course, when it's cooling, it's drying as
well and that would be a period of intense
stress and there were probably population
bottle necks at the time. And those may be
very important for evolution because if
you kill off 97% of the humans and you
just leave 3%, those will have characters
that will then be able to spread widely
without having to exchange with a large
gene pool. So you can get very powerful
evolutionary change through these
bottlenecks and what's remarkable about
these abrupt events is that they happen
again and again. There's not just one of
them. There's 25 of them in the last 100
thousand years and probably something like
20 and the 100 thousand years before that.
All told, our ancestors probably
went through a hundred of these
bottlenecks. So it's a repeated form of
boom and bust. William Calvin had a very
nice about this boom and bust evolutionary
pumping hypothesis. I'm going to switch
now to talk about the physical science
understand that we have about abrupt
climate change, what causes it in the
first place. And as I hinted at the
beginning is something to do with ocean
circulation, warm water at the surface in
the North Atlantic is carried by currents
to this place around Greenland where it
becomes cold and dense enough to sink and
then it travels southward along the bottom
of the ocean. And what this seems to do is
it actually displaces the earth's thermal
equator north of the geographic equator.
So the northern hemisphere today is quite
a bit warmer than the southern hemisphere.
And we believe that from theory and
evidence that this circulation is capable
of shutting off and so that's what a
cooling is and when it turns back on
that's what an abrupt warming is. This is
kind of what the paleo records look like
of this phenomenon of shutting on, turning
on and shutting off the North Atlantic
circulation. In northern records you see
abrupt warnings at the times when the
circulation goes on and in the southern
hemispheres, this is Antarctica, you
actually see a gradual warming during
times when the north is cold and then an
inflection point towards cooling, gradual
cooling in the south. And this is very
strong evidence that this really is the
ocean circulation. This is from a very
recent ice core that we drilled, just
finished, and we got published in Nature
few weeks ago.
This is one of the main findings from
this ice core is that because we can now
date the two hemispheres relative to each
other to precision of about 50 years we
can show that the norther abrupt warming
leads the southern transition to cooling,
which is shown here, by about 200 years
and that's very interesting because that
really confirms that this is the ocean
circulation that is doing this. I think
it's the latest in a long line of pieces
of evidence that support the notion that
it is this ocean circulation, sort of
oscillating and flipping on and off, it
does this. Will it happen again in the
near future? Is an abrupt climate change
something we have to worry about? Well you
may have seen the movie "The Day After
Tomorrow". It's something that's permeated
into the public consciousness but I think
the answer is probably not. And the reason
I say that is that the Atlantic ocean is
getting saltier today. In the last 50
years it's increased its salinity
dramatically. You can sort of see that in
this cartoon. The Atlantic is all yellow
which is an increase in salinity. The
Pacific has a lot of blue and that means
sort of a decrease in salinity. So what's
going on right now? Is that the Atlantic
is getting saltier. The Pacific is getting
fresher and that's exactly what we expect
to happen in a warming world because warm
air holds more water vapor. And so it's
possible to transport more vapor out of
the Atlantic into the Pacific, across
Panama you see here. So basically,
whenever the world gets warmer, the
Atlantic gets saltier and the salt
actually densifies the water, makes it
easier to sink. And it actually protects
that circulation. While there was some
worry maybe 15 years ago that Atlantic
circulation would shut
down due to global warming.
I think we can say now we've learned
something. Science moves on. It is now
very unlikely that this will happen again.
And the other, of course, is that we don't
have the amplifying factor of sea ice. Sea
ice makes the ocean turn from dark to
light. So it greatly exasperates the
effects of the overturning circulation
shutting off. So my take-home messages.
Hope I have convinced you that abrupt
climate change did stimulate farming and
there's a very, very interesting story
that's only just beginning to be
understood. It's very probable that many,
many abrupt climate changes prior to this
one, that stimulated farming, played a
roll by creating bottlenecks that made the
survivors of this event able to radiate
out into an empty niche after the event.
And very probably, I think also encouraged
people who could do things differently
than their parents were doing them. As I
have some kids who are becoming teenagers
I know a lot about this oppositional
"don't do what your parents were doing"
kind of stuff and I just wonder that maybe
that teenager kind of thing has its
origins in abrupt climate change. Because
if your parents are telling you to eat
fruit and the climate just crashed and you
say, "Oh, I do things differently than my
parents. I'm going to eat roots instead
of fruits, you might be the one
who actually survives
because you're a root eater. So I'm just
wondering if maybe these population
bottlenecks somehow encouraged contrarian
thinking. Atlantic Ocean overturning
circulation is the culprit, I think, we
can say now that causes abrupt climate
change. Will it happen again in the
future? Probably not. That's one thing we
can breathe easier about.
Check that one off the list.
More salt, less sea ice in our future.
Thank you.